I'll now introduce you to the
concept of a random variable.
And for me this is something
that I always had a lot of
trouble getting my head around,
and that's really because
it's a byproduct of
what it's called.
It's called a variable and
we're used to variables as kind
of an unknown in the equation.
If I write x plus 3 is equal
to 7, the variable was x.
Maybe you could solve for it
or maybe you could have an
equation y is equal
to 3x minus 2.
And then, here y and x
are both variables.
If you input 1x you could solve
for the other variable, y.
And you can change them.
And variables were kind of
things that could change and
that you could solve for.
And they could take on
particular values.
A random variable is kind of
the same thing in that it can
take on multiple values, but
it's not something that you
really ever solve for.
So just so you get used to the
notation, a random variable
is usually a capital letter.
Usually a Capital X, Y, or Z.
Usually a capital X.
And where it really defers from
a traditional variable is that
it can take on a bunch of
different values, like a
traditional variable but
you never solve for it.
And really, it's a little
misleading to call it
a variable at all.
It's really a function.
And it's a function that maps
you from the world of random
processes to an actual number.
So let's say-- I don't
know-- I wanted to somehow
quantify a random process.
Is it going to rain
or not tomorrow?
So let's see-- rain tomorrow.
No rain.
So you could observe that.
You could wait until tomorrow
and see if it rains or not, but
then, how do you quantify it?
Well, we can define a random
variable that will quantify it.
We can say this random variable
is going to be equal to 1 if it
rains tomorrow and it equals 0
if it doesn't rain tomorrow.
We didn't have to assign 1
and 0; those tend to be a
little bit more useful.
They make sense.
But we could have assigned this
as-- I don't know-- we could
have said that this is 21
and that this is 100.
It's however you define it.
So it's important to keep this
distinction in mind, that a
random variable-- it isn't a
variable in the traditional
sense of the world.
It's more of a function that
maps us from the world of a
random process to a number.
And then, this number
is going to be random.
Because we don't know if it's
going to rain or not tomorrow,
maybe we have some sense
of the probabilities.
So this variable can
take on either value.
And that leads us-- let me
draw a couple of more random
variable definitions just so
you get the intuition that
these really are functions.
So we could define a random
variable x as equal to--
well, actually, let me--
It could just be a very
obvious numeric mapping.
It could just be the
number facing up when
I roll a fair dice.
That's a random variable.
I could've also said just the
number most facing east when I
rolled a fair die, although
that's a little less useful.
You could also define a random
variable, x is equal to-- you
could say it's equal to 1 if
heads, and I could
say 0 if tails.
Or I could have done it
the other way around.
Once again, these heads
and tails are outcomes
of an experiment.
When I flip a coin that's a
random process, each flip is an
experiment and then the random
variable is just quantifying
that experiment.
So I know it sounds a little
technical with the terminology,
but what we're really doing
is fairly something simple.
We're just assigning a
1 if we get a heads, a
0 if we get a tails.
And the random variable is
just that function mapping.
Now I'm going into all of this
random variable business, which
I didn't do before when we did
probability because it does
start to become a little
bit useful notationally.
Because we'll start to talk
about things like probability
distributions and expected
values, and it really is
useful to quantify things
as a random variable.
And with that said, let's talk
about probability distributions
and expected values.
So the first thing,
probability-- actually, let
me define something else.
There's two types of
random variables.
You can have discrete random
variables, or continuous.
So there's two types.
Discrete would be like, really
all of the definitions
that we had up until now.
The flip of a coin, you're
either going to get a 1 or a 0.
There's two discrete cases.
When I roll a die there's
1 of 6 different
outcomes I can have.
Whether it rains
tomorrow, there's 1 of
2 outcomes: yes or no.
So in all of these situations
you could almost say you
could have accountable
number of outcomes.
A continuous random variable
could take on an infinite
number of outcomes.
So a continuous random variable
would be the exact-- it could
be x is equal to the exact
amount of rain in
inches tomorrow.
Now why is this continuous?
Well, if you think about it
that could take on any of
an infinite set of values.
You might have 1 inch of
rain tomorrow or you might
have 1.1 inches of rain.
You might have 1.111
inches of rain.
You might have 2.1111
As you could see, you can come
up with an infinite number
of combinations of the
amount of rain you have.
To get exact-- well, I'll go
into more of this when I
talk about probability
density functions.
But in general, even though you
might say, oh, well, I can't
imagine having an infinite
amount of rain because we're
not going to have 100
gallons of rain tomorrow.
But if you think about it, you
could take on any value between
1 and 2 inches of rain.
There's actually an
infinite number of
values between 0 and 1.
For any value you could find
a number that's a little--
just to think about it.
Between 0 and 1, 1/2
is in between those.
And you can always find a
number that's halfway between
those and then a number that's
halfway between those.
There's an infinite number
of numbers between
any two numbers.
While, with the discrete random
variables, it just took on
a finite number of values.
Those ones up here, it
could only take on 1 or 0.
It didn't take on 1.1.
Or it couldn't
take on infinity.
And I make that difference
because actually, how we look
at it in terms of their
probability distributions
are a little different.
But they're very related.
So a discreet random variable
like the ones that we had
defined at the beginning of
these videos, they have a
probability distribution.
Let's do it for-- let's say
x is equal to the number
facing up on a fair dice.
So we already know that
to get each outcome--
there's 6 outcomes.
You either can get a 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, or 6 facing up.
So let me draw the
probability distribution.
So here are all the outcomes.
I'll draw that on the
horizontal axis.
So you get one outcome
is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
And then, in the y-axis or in
the vertical, you plot what is
the probability of each of
those outcomes occurring?
What's the probability?
I'll switch colors.
So what's the probability
of getting a 1?
Well, it's 1/6.
So if I draw 1/6 here.
So the probability is of each
of these occurring-- oh, I
didn't want to do it
like that-- are 1/6.
It's essentially like a
histogram or a bar chart.
My intention is to draw them
all the exact same height.
So this is telling us that
each of these there's a 1/6
chance of it occurring.
If I were to draw a probability
distribution for-- if I were to
find the random variable
x is equal to 1 if
heads, 0 if tails.
This has a very simple
probability distribution.
There's only 2 outcomes.
You're either going
to get a 1 or a 0.
And then in the y-axis you'll
have the probabilities.
And each of these, if it's
a fair dice, it's going
to be a 1/2 probability.
And you're going to draw a
little box like that that tells
you each of them are 1/2.
Now let's say that you had
another-- I don't know--
probably distribution function
that looks something like this.
Those are kind of very run of
the mill examples, but what if
I had something like this?
Let's see.
Where I had some dice-- let's
say we had some weird
weightings on it where it had
an outcome of 1-- I had a
1/6 chance like that.
Let's say for some reason
a 2 could never happen.
Maybe there is no 2.
Let's say 3 has a 1/6 chance,
a 4 has a 1/6 chance,
a 5 has a 1/6 chance.
And let's say there's two 6's.
Like we erased the 2 and we
put a 6 where the 2 is,
so there's two 6's.
So the 6 has a 2/6 chance.
So the 6 would be a 2/6 chance.
So now I think you can see
where the probability
distribution function
starts to become a little
bit more interesting.
In the other ones it was kind
of what we would call a
uniform distribution.
All of the outcomes
are equally likely.
That's a uniform distribution.
Once again, this is a
uniform distribution.
This one, all of a sudden, is
not a uniform distribution.
1 is just as likely as 3, 4, 5.
2 is impossible to happen, but
6 is twice as likely to happen
as everything else-- is 2/6.
If someone gives you a
probability density function or
if they give you a little chart
like this, you can immediately
say, what's the probability of
different events occurring?
So if you said that x is equal
to the number on unfair dice
that's described by
this probability
distribution function.
Then if I were to ask you the
probability that x is equal to
6, you'd say, oh, the
probability x equals 6
is equal to 2/6 or 1/3.
If I were to say what's the
probability that x, the random
variable x as given by this
definition, is greater than 5,
you would take-- well, let's
say greater than or equal to 5.
Because you want to include
5, and at least, I did.
So it would include this
situation and this situation.
So it'd be 1/6 plus 2/6.
And so you could say
that's 3/6 or 1/2.
So it gets pretty interesting
once you don't have a
completely uniform
distribution.
And I'm doing all of this
because in the next couple of
videos-- well, one, we'll move
away from discreet and actually
study continuous probability
distributions, which are called
probability density functions.
And then we'll go to study kind
of a lot of distributions
that show up in nature.
The uniform distribution
is one of them.
There's also the binomial
distribution and the normal
distribution, which is
what some people call the
Gaussian or the bell curve.
Which is kind of a
very common thing.
But anyway, I'm all out
of time and I'll see
you in the next video.